good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast sorry we're a tad late
but you know what
that's what I've told those crazy times
you guys I missed my alarm this morning
I don't know if I forgot to set one or
if I turn it off in my sleep I'm
thinking I turned it off in my sleep I
can't believe that this actually doesn't
happen to us more often like thinking
recently I can't believe I've never
slept through the show and still like I
didn't sleep through the show because I
woke up at 956 and it is now 1036 so I
got dressed and I didn't look or
anything
thank you I but now I know what I can
get away with you know pretty much
impossible for me to miss the show
because my dog walker comes and rings my
doorbell which is the loudest thing ever
so I guess only would he have to like
sleep through his alarm and me sleep
through my ham for me to miss the show
but I often think that like in during
high school and like college I was
always sitting through my alarm like it
was something that happened to me all
the time but now it's like my body
pretty much like I will literally wake
up at 7:00 be like I'm where my alarm
didn't go off and then it's like no
[ __ ] you solve it I yeah usually same
for me but I guess I was just like so
tired I don't know I mean it's just like
we're business owners now our bodies
won't let us miss out on an opportunity
yeah I did I think and it's so so crazy
how when my alarm goes off like it takes
me like five snoozes until I can maybe
understand what's happening you know
usually my alarms like part of my dream
and like I I don't understand alarm as I
don't understand I'm being told to wake
up when my alarm is part of my dream
like I want to [ __ ] like blow up my
brain it's like shut the [ __ ] up like
it's so trippy and it's also so
frustrating I'm not going my dream am i
turn off your [ __ ] alarm like whoever
it's an alarm it is so it is the most
frustrating thing it is for have you
ever had dreams where it's like it's
those small dreams between your snoozes
where you're dreaming that you actually
woke up and got dressed course and I'm
like dreaming that I'm brushing my teeth
yeah or in my dream I'm turning off the
alarm and I'm like how whose alarm is
someone turn it off yeah so I guess
that's what happened today anyways the
policies for the few minutes late I
thought it was gonna be like an actual
do I did you make 30 minutes but um I'm
here well it's very exciting times here
because you know it's just a good old
Wednesday but it's also officially the
start of winter because I've cracked out
my period sweater
Wow every year and I think this is my
third period sweater every year that was
our third winter on the toast actually I
get a sweater not on
purpose that just like happens to mimic
the various stages of a menstrual cycle
and that saying officially know that
it's winter New York so this is from
forever 21 it was actually gift for my
mother-in-law thank save up and happy
winter love it you want to know what how
else you can know it's winter because
the winter presets are out y'all oh yes
a alright thank you
whoa I just dropped no rhyme no reason
other than tis the season how do you
spell Jackie O Flo's hair W or no of
course slow calm yeah Jackie O Flo calm
everything's there all the packs the
winter pack is out now and I'm selling
six for the price of five cuz I'm just
feeling generous what ocean is various
woman QVC I know well you know what I
like
I had six and I was like trying to
whittle it down I was like might as well
give them em all totally they looked
really good I did download them today
but I think the hardest part about I'm
now that I like pretty much rely on
presets for my income I think the
hardest part is figuring out how to get
them into Lightroom like I'll watch all
the videos I'm still just gonna have to
hand over my phone to you and I've been
doing yeah I'll do it it's it's so much
quicker but actually something with the
new phone update at least when I did it
on my phone made it even easier than
usual so I have to check my customer
service emails but I didn't hear that
many complaints you're so cute like yeah
you need that winter flow you guys
definitely you do its anytime you're
taking pictures at the dirty jeans tour
and it's like a dark Theater you
definitely need Jackie O flow once you
get your tickets are girls right and now
I have a preset called flash for flash
photography because those are the
[ __ ] words flash photography is
source but some by the way I have
absolutely no interest in getting the
new iPhone except though this weekend
degree I I did my mean green and I opted
for selfies this time cuz I went to a
Kacey Musgraves meeting greeting it was
like she don't ring light no snow
premium so I had them put up a light and
like we did selfies and actually really
likes it except my arm really hurt but
it got me thinking I was taking pictures
and like some of the ones on the iPhone
like they just have a built-in ring
light like it's the new iPhone has like
this new feature where it's so bright
and like warm tones and I actually think
I'm gonna get the iPhone just because of
it also when you take a photo on the
other camera the three firm there's a
new feature where you can zoom out like
anytime point five and so you get more
see you
have to take a step back and you get
more scenery oh and juice today so smoke
should we go get new iPhones - I think
we should like for our trip initially
cause probably like around the grand
whatever happened to getting an iPhone
upgrade no I mean when you when I was in
high school you were due for an upgrade
like you had the bright new phone for
like a hundred bucks yeah those were the
days I guess but then you were always
like waiting for your upgrade chuckles
or snagging your upgrades in your family
and also that's true
that is true also the finish the thing
that we use most in this world and
everyone's like looking for a discount
it's like it's like a beating heart like
I'm not looking for a discount but I'm
definitely just like I'm not gonna I'm
not as quick like I'm not gonna be the
first person because my phone works
perfectly fine I feel so silly but like
technically the phone should be the
thing that you're willing to pay the
most for because aside from you know
like a necessary vital organ yeah okay
the phone pays our bills and and not
even but it's everyone like it's your
whole life yeah and I guess that's why
they make it so expensive and people
don't like I don't really hear people
complaining about the price of milk I
think they could be making them more
expensive honestly because no one no
one's not gonna get the phone
you know everyone finds a way to get
their phone yeah yeah and no and people
don't complain about the price it's like
Oh $1,200 and getting a new phone it
could've been $2,000 and getting a new
phone yeah that's how I feel all right
so please don't be surprised yeah
generates the price so you could are you
good
um we're gonna recap Real Housewives of
Orange County was anything else on last
night no she says her slow no just were
Hoke and then what did I watch we're
jealous tonight oh yeah oh I watch and I
watch to watch Robbins live I watched a
movie on II called enough with general
okay the scariest [ __ ] movie like I I
only got like a quarter of the way but I
recorded the rest oh my god me and Ben
one time fell into it it was on cable
like on e or something we were freaking
out I couldn't sleep for months it is
the scariest Megan can see the scary
part she's about to like leave the house
with her daughter but then he comes and
stops her and then I oh wow you really
turned it off at the peak like he comes
in stop start put the daughters in the
house right she's carrying it on day
right she takes the daughter so he won't
be yeah and you're waiting in the car
and then yes so great so anyways it's
like almost unrealistic like how much
like he comes after them like you know
what I mean yeah it's so crazy but it's
really crazy like the movies we love on
ER always things that I've known and
I've seen backwards and forwards so to
have
never even heard before was cool well
that is what happened to me with that
movie obsessed with Beyonce and Ali
Larter and interest Elba it was I
couldn't believe I'd never seen it it
was on USA like a movie like I always
know the movies on there it is the
craziest [ __ ] movie like Ali Larter
is insane Beyonce and her like literally
almost kill each other in the final
scene such a good movie highly recommend
like doesn't get enough praise okay
check it out oh I think it was the no it
wasn't the toast movie of the week you
chose two children the children which
was the toast movie of the week I have
absolutely no regrets it's an
interesting movie when they're in light
it's a problem that makes you think it's
Kate Winslet spy this work if you ask me
and therein lies the issue it's a great
movie and I love anything Google with
Patrick Wilson he's so hot and he's like
not as big of a stars he should be for
being so incredibly good-looking like in
every facet of his life you know I think
he's like a just a true actor you know
ya know guys in a Lebanese he is an
actor like by trade you know and he's
been in so many big things he was in
morning glory oh my god
he's her lovely jism Morning Glory
everything comes back to Morning Glory
and these don't swing girls like the
worst episode of all time where he plays
the doctor at the town house that I like
would never want to hook up with someone
as annoying as Lena Dunham
so just somebody think about when when
this year's Oscar nominations come out
okay like where is Patrick Wilson yeah
well no I'm too much like Taylor Swift
at the Grammys
yep we're gonna get to the sonam's
because without further ado it's time
for the past five stories that you yes
you you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast no I mean I got aggressive there
and it's definitely time and I I don't
want anyone to be confused as to whether
or not it's time cuz like it's
definitely [ __ ] time but but I would
be like remiss I would be devastated I
would be heartburn so if I didn't let
you know that today's episode is brought
to you by fabletics
if you want to take a quick 60 second
style pop quiz for personalized outfit
recommendations
fabletics it's for you Margeaux actually
got me into fabletics and then i heard
that a quiz and i was like oh my god i
love a quiz I'm yep I feel so good and
teacher I put I feel so [ __ ] seen
when there's a quiz because it's like
they're not just gonna send me stuff
that like people who know nothing about
me like please send me yeah so you can
shop from thousands of styles curated
for you really cute athleisure they have
tons of amazing
and you know I live for leggings for
about 10 years of my life I only wore
leggings as pants like I didn't even
know what jeans wear so you can check
out as a guest on fabletics or you can
become a VIP and there's tons of perks
when being a VIP you can get up to 50%
off regular prices free shipping and
additional perks literally the prices
are so low like you actually think it's
like not real but I'm telling you it is
you just have to become a VIP member
it's real you guys it's amazing so take
a super quick 60 second style quiz
you'll receive a personalized showroom
of pieces specifically catered towards
your own unique style this takes the
guesswork out of what styles are best
suitable for you with just a few clicks
fabletics is doing all the homework for
you and right now you guys can get to
leggings for only $24 it's a $100 value
but if you're a VIP even get the two
leggings for only $24 using our special
link I have like maybe four pairs of
leggings from fab fabletics and I have
to say the best part is that they don't
write down I hate when you have like
drag like low crotch in your leggings
and then like you're Trevor I'm starts I
can't yeah and I like a good elasticity
in my leggings but not too tight that I
can't breathe agreed so if you're
anxious to get in shape and feel
confident stepping into your workout
routines with trendy and affordable gym
where we highly recommend checking out
fabletics and trust us you do not want
to miss out on their very special offer
to leggings for $24 a $99 value for when
you sign up as a VIP be sure to check
out our favorite leggings head to
fabletics comm slash toast to get two
pairs of leggings for only $24 that's
fabletics comm slash toast the best part
is that there's no commitment to
purchase monthly and free shipping on
all your orders over $49 so make sure
you enter your email address when you
take the style quiz as you'll receive
exclusive discounts and the inside scoop
about new collections that haven't been
released yet go to fabletics comm slash
toast
again that's fabletics comm slash toast
you get two pairs of leggings for only
$24 and conditions they do apply but
it's worth it yet to sign on and feel as
good as you possibly can while working
out which is also very difficult I got a
pair of sneakers from fabletics oh yes
you've been wearing them a lot very cool
and I've never seen you like rock
sneakers I know I struggle in the
sneaker Department I'm gonna share a
weird piece of information I am like
almost 100 percent sure I have an
ingrown hair on my knuckle Wow and it
kind of hurts
yeah just want to share in addition to
this [ __ ] crater on my face I mean
let me see I've covered it up so
hardcore today I'm so glad I sit on this
side because if i sat on there I would
act
make you switch sides with me just for
the week because I have it was a big
pimple but I made it worse by going at
it with a pair of tweezers it's like
non-stop and that's an obnoxious but
like I don't really get pimples a lot
and I love to pop pimples like I'm
always popping pens so it's like it was
an exciting day for me and I just I had
to go at it and I think I might have
popped a few blood vessels I might leave
a scar I don't know it's really bad so
I'm just really grateful to be sitting
right here so you can only see the left
side of my face whereas the right side
of my face is very much crater central
got it okay well now it really is time
it definitely is because you were
confused and you should have been
because apparently it wasn't time no it
wasn't but now it is and now it is the
first story of the day the biggest story
of the day the Grammy nominations are
you out the Grammys nominations the sub
nations are out some nominations very
Intune some nominations not so much all
the awards list was gotten very Intune
like she really this was her year yeah
and I feel really sad that she might not
win new artist of the year because it
might go to Billy Eilish because like
everyone's obsessing her and I don't
really understand it but like I'm happy
for them I understand it so I'm worried
because her and her and Billy Eilish
like the top artists in terms of number
of nominations and I feel like Billy
Eilish might be that Liz oh when I think
those those deserving
yeah well Billy Eilish did win um you
know the MTV Award for it so what is any
indicator right okay here the
nominations from the important category
the nominees are album of the year III
by Bon Iver definitely didn't say that
right
boney there bunny there oh my god when I
was in high school and there was like a
year where everyone was obsessed with
boney Barry was like all the guys were
so like a couple girls like yes would
ever seen bunny bear video city and I'm
like you guys are [ __ ] losers and I'm
really feel proud of myself that I never
like succumb to the king is that past
tense it's to come - yeah - peer
pressure like just so boys would like me
and like pretended to like bony bear cuz
he was a loser and they keep one at the
Grammys and ever was like oh yeah um I
just can't believe it's boney there when
it's clearly says that I'm no I know
it's very confusing like this Norman
[ __ ] Rockwell by Lana Del Ray who
knew she even put out an album this year
this is not in tune no I knew and it was
critically acclaimed I could not for us
but I not every award is gonna be your
feet okay I completely agree but I had I
work in pop culture we do the show every
goddamn day and I love
music and I had no idea that Lana Del
Rey putting out an album this year
honestly that's on you because and also
I came out and this I think the same
weekend his lover so like maybe it was
just oh it got over cloudy but like I
fully I don't I don't like the album and
I'm not Lana Del Rey's number-one fan
but like I respect the choice like she
is truly an okay okay I believe and if
it came out the same days love her and
this may be the only way that this could
have slipped through the cracks okay
when we fall asleep where do we go
Billie Eilish okay thank you next Ariana
Grande okay I want to talk about that
because while thank you next the single
was really like prolific like it broke
records took the world by storm everyone
was singing it no matter what age what
country like everyone singing it but the
album like is not good
I disagree what what songs are on that
album um I just can't me not like I
think once you seven rings and all of
these songs like really hit the charts
like honestly thank you next sometimes
they don't do this where they don't give
it to the chart-topper but thank you
next is the number one album charts why
what was the album she released a
sweetener oh okay this isn't sweet this
isn't a sweetener sweetener is not it
sweeteners not it thank you next is a
lot closer to fine fine I just think
like when the Grammys like okay whatever
it's like I used to know her by her I
don't know her but I think a lot of
people respect her and therefore I
respect the choice and I'm not upset
about it
seven lil nas ex huh no this is where I
draw the line because okay little minds
I've had an amazing year don't get me
wrong because of one song you know and I
just think like album of the year like I
challenge you to name one song off that
album panini I challenge you to name
another like I mean I just think that in
it's like when you think of I obviously
him comparing everything to Taylor Swift
because she did not get nominated in
this category even though she outsold
all these albums her album sold almost a
million copies in the first week like I
just think first of all that has to mean
something second of all the album is so
good like I didn't really get that upset
when reputation wasn't nominated last
year because it wasn't my favorite album
and even though I do think it deserved
to me at least nominated the problem of
the year just because of the amount of
accolades I thought I'm the amount of
numbers had it sold like I didn't I
didn't put my fork in the ground my
stake in the ground yeah I'm putting my
stake in the ground now because lover is
literally so good in this agreement
Lamaze acts like for half the year like
he was like his sons weren't like a joke
until like they were taken seriously
like come on look this is upsetting cuz
I love you bye Liz oh of course
of course father of the bride by Vampire
Weekend interesting I'm I'm here to say
no yeah I mean if we just not meeting
like random albums like I'd like to
nominate the bright young album right
we're just picking like album got about
obscurity like that or die's it know
like good really good albums but like
I'm sorry it's just not cramming
material ya know it's a this is really
random like I want to get like [ __ ]
like I'm Matt Nathanson album about here
like we're just being random no but like
we're just like these are like just
someone's picking like albums that they
enjoyed ya know it's like whose playlist
is this coming from
yeah no that was just a weird choice
that I respect it but when looking
through this category list as through
the lens of Taylor strip being snubbed
it's like it's that much more
frustrating yeah it is because it should
be a combination of like the Academy's
like particular art artistry and the
fans
yeah and I'm sorry being selling but you
know I feel two ways because I think
just because like you're popular it's
almost like the conversation we had
about BTS like they Janaka nominate then
their army is in arms but it's like just
because you're popular does that mean
you get nominated for a Grammy I don't
know in the words of Kanye West I hear
you got to sell us a smash two Grammy
yet popular + talented I would say right
and that's to me is the definition of
Taylor Swift like I think a lot of
people write her off because she's so
popular but then they're always
surprised when it's like she writes all
of her own songs and like she really is
very very talented yeah so I'm just like
I'm set I'm not gonna lie this is two
years in a row getting snow by the
Grammys in last year like I didn't say a
lot because I didn't really like love
reputation to the point where I wanted
to fight anxiety like and the Grammys
are supposed to know these things like
reputation is an incredible album you
know yeah that's the Taylor Swift effect
yeah okay so who would you give album of
the year to given these choices uh Liz
oh yeah who were the first not wanted
everybody there a lot of over a billion
obviously it's gonna be between it's so
crazy because they're both also new
artists and it's gonna be between Billy
Eilish and Liz oh but I would love to
see Ari win album of the era Grammy like
she doesn't put that with shakin Awards
and like she wouldn't know what to say
her
and it would be hilarious yeah it would
be hilarious if she didn't go last year
and she was nominated than she won wow
it would be hilarious but I don't know
seven rings yeah maybe maybe
okay I wonder if Taylor will go I feel
like no she was nominated Lester and she
did not go yeah and she's not meet in
like [ __ ] categories that's like
what ariana was nominated in last year
and she did not go yeah okay song of the
year always remember us this way random
look why wouldn't it be shallow yeah cuz
shallow was the year before
oh but still like always were more
certainly doesn't get played on the
radio it's so weird no but it's really
beautiful it was some of my ear I make
you I think it's literally one of the
best songs ever bad guy yeah bring my
flowers now Brandi Carlile no hard place
her lover
Taylor Swift Oh bring my flowers now
it's tan you Tucker
but um Brandi Carlile rode on it
lavertus norman talking rock well I'm
Dale rice someone you love blue miss
Capaldi I love this choice I really is
any song of the year and Oh truth hurts
my Liz oh it's game over and that's the
one that was 17 weeks on the Billboard
number one but this is the category
where Old Town Road should be nominated
because that was the song of the year by
definition
I completely agree it broke all the
records and that's where it's like it
should be no it should be recognized by
the Grammys because it did take the
world by storm this year but I love the
Year by little mouths like that is so
random yes and then here's what's
confusing his record of the year I'll
never know the nucleus hey MA bye Bonnie
there bad guy by Billy Eilish seven
rings ariana grande a hard place her
talk Khalid Old Town Road lil NAS action
Billy Cyrus truth hurts Liz o sunflower
post Malone oh you know I love that
sound I could see like five out of six
of these women totally I think that's
good good stuff totally I think Old Town
woman record of the year Michu truth
hurts wind song of the year but just as
her sunflower my friends because it's a
great song I agree I mean you're a puss
one Stan I'm loving host Malone I'm so
late to the game and I hear a song ten
times before before Debbie I was talking
about puss one like when I was in
college I met someone with him and I
used to be friends okay yes we did you
can either that's possible and used to
be friends
none of that's true 100% I knew why I
ever said before everyone did and then
like we became friends with him no
longer friends cause it's like a little
busy but me and Ben you speak myself I
had pictures with a post Milan but
that's you have a picture because no you
met him no I had multiple pictures I met
him like four times yeah I don't believe
Chelsea it's a disease I don't believe
her okay what okay show us the pictures
happily for different scenarios you know
what I'll find it later I promise I'll
post on the tussin for different
scenarios sure would for different
outfits you got it um also with his new
song seasons of love go away we're gonna
do for copyright because we're singing
it means that I don't think it'll be
able to see okay best new artist black
Pumas Billy eyelash lil nas Exley's Oh
Maggie Rodgers Rosalia tank and the bang
us Yola there's a couple people in there
who like I could see really taking it
like Rosalia for sure but if it was any
other year like this is the year of
Billy eyelash this is the year of Liz oh
and I just don't us mmm it's the year of
Lil knows it was the year of Old Town
Road it's year it's the year of Loomis I
just it's sad for all the other people
cause like they're not gonna win you
know no Maggie Reiser is like in this
she in another world she definitely
could have won like she's really
impressive here yeah thanks
it's definitely hurts truly just an
honor to be nominated Maggie Rogers
Wow Liz oh and Millie is must be having
a great day yeah Billy Ilyitch I think
got more oh so did you hear about the
leak leaking vibes yeah of the Grammy
nominations like the nominations weren't
leaked but the web say was automatically
updated like every pay every artist has
a page and ass like Taylor Swift
35 nominations and then yesterday and
went up to 38 like every artist and
those numbers ended up being right oh
but it said you just knew how many times
people were nominated not what they were
actually nominated for but so I said
Billy Eilish was nominated for a liz'
was nominated for six and Taylor's -
Ariana were both nominated for three
it's not the Game of Thrones finale like
if my Grammy nominations are spoiled
I'll be okay no and it's like the number
of nominations like I somehow will find
a way to go on with my life okay
Best Pop Vocal album The Lion King the
by Beyonce when we fall asleep where'd
we go Billy Eilish thank you next Ari
number six collaborations project ed
sheeran lover Taylor Swift wow this is
such an insult to lover and honestly I
think that Billy Eilish might take it
because I mean I don't stand Bailey
Irish but just like knowing the state of
the world I think actually Billy Eilish
might might take it
I think Ari might take it if she doesn't
win anything else there were a lot of
good albums is here tonight I think
about it
sort of I'm just hosting the Grammys of
Alicia Keys yeah she puts on quite a
show yeah okay let's go to the country
category so we can be pissed off best oh
my god and so we can be irate best
country solo performance all yarn Tyler
child errs who go goin nowhere Ashley
McBride who ride me back home Willie
Nelson
God's country Blake Shelton okay bring
my flowers now tanga Tucker where the
[ __ ] is beer never broke my heart my
friends well so um it came out in May no
beer oh is a song country solo
performance oh so it's not album so Luke
combs oh no no combs is how eligibility
has to come out before September in
order for August 31st so if you never
broke my heart is like the country song
of all time I couldn't anymore now in
the spring I agree huge snub huge snub
so best country song is bring my flowers
now Tanya Tucker girl going nowhere
Ashley McBride it all comes out in the
wash Miranda lamb or actually live that
song some of it Eric Church speechless
Saanich a cute but I just like ice
Country Music's number-one fan for me to
know only two out of the five songs like
this is how you know the Recording
Academy is not in tune at all when it
comes to country yeah wait I just
remembered that out of the years like
such a big deal like now I'm remembering
that Casey just wanted this ain't your
life so oh my god never wins it's like I
actually think it's gonna be Lissa oh it
could be Billy Eilish look at her yeah
she is she's so quiet you know she just
like gets now and she's not like
annoying about it and can explain like
she's not thirsty on Instagram like
she's not dotty like she just really has
gone to her she is based on her merits
and I think that's actually really
impressive so I would not be upset if
she won yeah no not sure today she's
also coming out with a kids clothing
line it looks really cute I thought it
does look really cute so that's cute
that's also like an interesting next
step yeah you know mm-hmm it's not so
traditional no I like I really respect
I respect her on that song bad guys
really grown it's been a year now one
more thing I wanted to say that actually
told Margo in confidence the other day
that I'm actually like ashamed to admit
it's not like I actually been really
low-key liking Miranda Lambert's new
music and like you know I was her
biggest critic but the thing about me is
like I will critique you when you're bad
and I will come for you when in a
positive way like when I am and I think
that song all comes down the wash is so
good I thought she looked so kind of
like you too CMAs like her little bubble
thing was like very cute I think that
that new song lemonade is also really
cute and I just wanted to put it out
there cuz when I speak badly about
someone I have to speak good when I feel
it so I think Miranda Lambert is doing
good things and she calmed down with
like the crazy drama love life and it's
yeah he seems like she's in a good place
she's matched like I miss her yeah she's
a cutie okay
are we are we all squared away on Grammy
nominations yeah just one more time
justice for Taylor Swift [ __ ] the entire
Recording Academy they've never
respected her ever since they gave album
of the year to random-access memory
instead of red and everyone thought they
were saying red also for Best New Artist
when they put out black Puma all the
black pink fans were like freaking out I
was on like a kpop Twitter this morning
and all the the I don't know what the
fan base calls themselves but black pink
they were like black Puma and they were
like excuse me
Black team fans are freaking out also
BTS army is really really not I'm in a
good place
he's very upset well the broadcast is on
January 26 so the day after my show the
weekend which is sold out but you wanna
come to another trip tickets bail bail
girl no job job calm Verona New York
we're gonna be turning stones at the
turning shows gonna turn those two and
sell you guys do not be by OS Kansas
City Missouri Atlantic City New Jersey
everything Stone will provide the stone
for everyone to turn after the show
though after the other ones yet likes
you crazy they'll be like a ceremonial
turning of the stone and go in New
Jersey and Atlantic City New Jersey you
don't want to miss it that's all so your
pee-can show us on a Sunday night
Saturday I have a conflict but obviously
what you know like I'll be there what's
the complex about Mar Mitzvah oh okay
well you can't go and now they can Zack
okay and you know that you're in charge
of sorry the after party and now it's
like we're kind of like close like can
you get on it yeah yeah why do you think
you might throw a great soiree you're
the Events Committee and I'll give you
like a pretty small budget and you said
to make it work have to give me a
generous budget plus payment Oh are you
you take a commission a party planner
for free okay are you ready for our next
story yeah I'm like a case of someone
somewhere things justice is being served
but spoiler alert it's not as Epstein
died guards allegedly shocked online and
slept relatable honestly me as a prison
guard so right now these two prison
guards are under scrutiny they're being
investigated investigated because they
obviously you know drop the ball and
they didn't check on him and they
falsified the records but this like is
going to like a larger theory that oh
they didn't check on him allowing him to
commit suicide and also they're saying
that no one entered his cell during this
time so like this thing people are like
oh my god we're finally getting justice
like what no they're just further
proving that he committed suicide which
we know that he did it I keep seeing
stories about this and it's like I don't
even care cuz I know we're never gonna
get to the resolution of like really who
was it like was it the Clintons like who
was it like I want to know so we're
never gonna get there so every time I
see a headline I don't even get myself
excited about it but honestly like the
the public's knowledge and like they're
the public's unwillingness to just like
believe everything that media tells I'm
like that's the real win here for me and
I'm happy knowing that everyone knows
Epstein didn't kill himself like I
literally I don't even need it in in in
the form of any real justice like just
everyone knowing is justice enough for
me does that make sense
yes and I feel it's better than you know
us like you know peddling conspiracy
theories over here but like it's really
crazy that like everyone can know
something and then you know the
narrative is like it's just crazy what
kind of like what world we live in
well that's like the justice system like
Casey Anthony it's like everyone
obviously knows that she did it yeah but
like she's a free woman
well many people think Oh Jay did it but
that's nicely but that's that's
different cuz that's just like that's
the court system and it has its flaws
but that's our justice system this is
like everyone will continue to tell us
that after you I've seen you kill
themself as if we're like children and
we're gonna believe it right um no
matter how much like it's so clear
not trace how much for the children's
book but I've seen didn't kill himself
just so the children of the next
generation will not be silenced yeah so
here are the deeds to jail guards
responsible for monitoring Jeffrey
Epstein the night he killed himself
hooey like they're still saying the
night he killed himself they died this
is the problem but now how many people
have to say like it should be the night
he killed himself like a P you're not in
tune with what's necessary this is the
problem right here herein lies the issue
here is for sure man that she is
according to an indictment released
Tuesday charging the guards with lying
on prison records to cover themselves
yeah it's their fault the prison guards
the grand jury indictment provides a
damning glimpse of safety lapses inside
of hi sorry he's high security unit at
the Metropolitan Correctional Center in
New York where Epstein had been awaiting
trial on sex trafficking charges
the indictment leaning in part on images
from security cameras on the cell box
also contains new details reinforcing
the idea that for all the intrigue
regarding Epstein and his connections to
powerful people his death was a suicide
and possibly preventable okay that now
they're talking to us I go for all the
intrigue right not in treatment no
they're addressing the memes who are not
intrigued we're certain no no I'm not
even certain I am 100% convinced well
I'm certainly like this is so [ __ ]
condescending yeah get that [ __ ] out of
my face oh I'm done reading her it's
insulting look patronizing it really is
condescending and just when I thought
like you Jeffrey Epstein memes we're
becoming too much and I was over them
bring on the hand the post another one
today bring him on yeah let's do not
forget ya Jeffrey Epstein did kill
himself this changes nothing
nothing just now I know I'm not the only
one with it online shop ya know now I'm
more certain than ever and a sleep
addiction yeah
by the way like locate I actually feel
like when you know when people like list
off the jobs they would never want to
have like garbage man shoveling [ __ ] at
the circus I would never want to be a
prison guard yeah I watch too much TV
now then I get to shop and sleep right
actually doesn't sound so bad II be I am
job what is the job you would never want
to have shoveling [ __ ] at the circus I
mean you know I actually I know my job
then I would also have to be at this
circus maybe PT Barnum would be there ya
know - yes I would like my like a job
that I would literally I would rather be
a garbage man I would rather have any
job in the world then be work on a beach
like in set up chairs it's so true and
it's so physically laborious and I have
so much respect and it's usually like
dudes who can handle it but like I see
everybody you aren't a hero like that is
a job I would never ever have like I'm
so out of shape I would think on the
beach like somebody that kinda shares
and I would literally like no yeah no
that's like I totally hear you
but what's craziest for someone like for
some people especially like young like
high school kids that's like such a
great job because you get to be on the
beach home and you make tons of cash in
tips and it's like be in a bikini but
like yeah for me like if someone who
would rather die than be in the bikini
and it has an aversion to the Sun like I
can't think of a worse job yeah I can't
think of a worse job for the two of us
yeah that's rough yeah I want to see
toasters post in the comments with some
of with the job you would never want to
have someone said mortician oh you know
what also job I wouldn't I I just
couldn't do and this week's episode of
the snatchler was reminding me of it
like people who work in HR who like it's
their job to make like the interviewees
feel comfortable and like being like a
normal person they might not get the job
no be just like talk like just being
like person they'll also like a broker
like I could just cannot talk that long
to strangers all day yeah you know
that's literally what you do no but I
talk to you yeah and then people want
Rangers but no like making just like
small talk all day like that is my that
would be the death of me yeah I'm
standing in heels like another
suggestions people wouldn't never want
to be a plumber no every time I've ever
played a Palmeiras [ __ ] expensive so
yeah truck driver love to be a truck
driver like I would be alone all the
time just listening to music and I love
a rest stop agree I think the truck
driver is the best job listening to
music the whole time listening to music
podcasts the morn each house and then
it's like I love a rest stop so much
like the best food is at a rest stop
fountain soda 7-elevens wawas like I
think that I mean I love a road trip
like I would love to be a truck driver
yeah 100% again they set up camp yeah
and by the trucks are huge like you get
so much space and I'm saying come on
truck are we driving
right no is it like is it a Walmart
18-wheeler like what is it yeah is it
like ooh a customer service a customer
service representative that's good you
get the brunt of people's [ __ ] yeah
that's a good answer that is a good
answer
cosmetic animal tester oh that's sad I
actually agree with that these are great
answer
oh wax are for sure yeah
interesting interesting a question okay
are you ready for our next story yes you
do
I don't you don't I I don't seem ready
because it's 11:10 and I'm looking at
the clock just waiting for it to turn to
11:11 let's spend the next minute
thinking of our wishes okay let me let
me think I wish for lots of success and
money for to the world peace real peace
of course and harsher punishments or I
love forever huh baggage baggage baggage
episode episode episode episode Network
show justice very Jeffrey Epstein and
Jessica girls justice for exact receipts
murderer and just for the girls okay
yeah like justice because also sometimes
justice is like it's not always like
justice it's like justice I want justice
free Decker scenes murder but do we want
justice in him yes because he took away
our chance like yeah now what like you
could steal like they're still doing it
they just write a person who probably
would have gotten away with they took
away our chance they took away our
chance and that's not how the justice
system works
you don't take justice into your own
hands another job people are saying that
whenever one is a 9-1-1 operator totally
agree to watch that show 9-1-1 no we
know but it looks so good it does it's
with um Connie Britton Peter crafts
excuse me Peter Krause Peter Krause he's
on it from The Bachelor there's an actor
named Peter Krause there is yeah oh my
god you see Peter Krause left the most
precious
comment on our Instagram no when they
were announcing the new city for Real
Housewives but they haven't announced it
yet I was like what are your guesses and
he said Madison Wisconsin it's a great
out it was the cutest most precious
[ __ ] comment I love that he's so
Wisconsin strong yeah hard core and it's
like you know that the pain gets him
like he's standing Wisconsin with a run
for mayor of Wisconsin 1,000% governor
okay
sorry finally I think we're ready
Jennifer Lopez says she did hustlers for
free quote I Bank on myself Jennifer
Lopez doesn't work for free unless it's
on her own terms I think I paid a whole
bunch of money for hustlers - the 50
year old told GQ for their 2019 men of
the year issue released on Monday I did
it for free and produced it I Bank on
myself you know that was like Jenny from
the block I do what I want I do what I
love so she didn't do it for free
because she got paid as a producer and
she's getting like royalties right now
and most people these days will forego a
an upfront salary for a back end of the
movie Keanu Reeves was actually the
first person to do that so you'll make
way more money if the movie is
successful so it's like I think all the
kids from Shrek did that and made tons
of money so she's betting on herself
that she produces a successful movie a
successful movie yes well I believe it
was successful I still haven't seen it
um I saw it it's great I mean 33 million
opening weekend I think it's about like
a hundred and thirty box office
worldwide now I really but it's still in
like random theaters and I don't want to
see it at home like I want to see it
you should go see it it's so good maybe
I'll do that tonight or something I
think it really is so good
I just learned one of the movies to be
like so difficult I can't explain that
yeah no I agree you should see hustlers
yes I should it and I will it's kind of
a feature film at home sometimes yeah
you always make it up better in your
head than it is we're gonna make popcorn
yeah oh my god I've immediately and he
ever made popcorn and they've recently
come to the decision that the TV and my
bedroom is far too far away from my bed
and I can't see and that like I got
glasses but it still doesn't help look I
need a TV that's I've been watching
stuff on my computer even that comes
down from the ceiling
literally because I cannot stand like my
TV being so far away from me it's just
something to think about that is
something about my TV is so big and
close like I'm like a little old person
I like that with a magnifier remember
like when we were kids do you think it
would go blind if you like watch the TV
to close yeah or if you actually too
much IDI like yeah look by the way I
watch too much TV as I can't look at me
now I'm a star no I watch too much TV as
a kid and they watch even more now yeah
for my job yeah okay next we actually
did a great patron episode yesterday if
you want to check it out morning
patreon.com slash in the morning toast
it was all about like our business our
scheduling how we organize staff who's
responsible for what and we actually
made you a part two because we don't get
to like have
yeah and people were just loving the
logistics of it all it's like we always
asked everyone else about it we'll just
take a bloody reality TV yeah so people
were asking us about our logistical
nightmares yes it's oh there's just
school logistics check it out
patreon.com slash morning toes we have
three more episodes coming to this month
we'll be doing some patreon episodes
while we're on family vacation next week
um it's just good stuff very good stuff
okay our next story is like something
that I just loved and it was a passion
story for me to choose you know just
something that like really spoke to me
okay
because ariana grande just had a mini
victorious reunion at her concert okay
so I saw and her Liz Gillies were
tweeting at each other yesterday like a
big surprise there's something and I was
so curious and this is what it is and
honestly it's exactly what I would have
wanted no I couldn't have imagined
anything better and like not only did
they perform together and she came um
for thinking accident it's Santa costume
like thank you incredible love it.next
but they performed the song from a
notorious snow it's so give it don't
know what you bond by but your hand it's
just bond as a fan you know sometimes
your button button button but I don't
know man and I believe it's called give
it up so good when they are doing
karaoke and like they see those Mean
Girls in the karaoke bar you know yeah
such a good episode she could episode
that's that show had such a good
soundtrack but something very
interesting that this article probably
won't tell you but I got in a DM someone
was out the show someone said that
ariana shouted out someone in the
audience who was there and it was Dan
Schneider no yeah no yeah no I know that
I wasn't sure I just got it as a DM from
someone who is in the audience but I
kind of believe it no what did she know
it mean it's weird cuz like what we know
about tan Schneider is like what we know
but like the kids from Victorious and
the kids from Zoey 101 are like always
taking pictures of them tweeting and I'm
like they don't have a bad thing to say
about him it's so weird
some of them do Nicole oh yeah one of
them does from Iran who'd she play you
win no who's the coal she was booted
after season one because she wasn't down
with the feet I'm sorry Ben as women you
know it was a great addition to the cast
like her just her spirit on the show and
then they were placed here with like
that moodier girl yeah so I think her
name was Dana yeah um but we never got a
spirit like Nicole again um I was
actually Benison obsessed with watching
Drake and Josh because it's on Hulu and
they didn't realize till last night
asleep I heard at the end it said the
Schneider bakery like that's his
production company and I was like we
can't watch this anymore but the show is
weird like if you watch it through the
lens of like a pedophile having wrote it
like iostream
it is incredibly odd like there's so
many weird like sexual innuendos that
like we're definitely not appropriate
for us kids to be watching and then if
you also think about it like the show is
just so funny cuz if you think of weird
Josh Peck ended up I'm wearin trach
balance about like you would have
thought it would've been the total
opposite like they positioned josh is
like this loser like i need the star now
and he's like so hot Marik's like the
most beautiful woman I'm like just not
happening for Drake like he's I think
he's like an O in a bad place yeah he
always reminds me of that guy from he
reminds me the iron quarter you the guy
from stepbrothers Adam Scott you know
they do look alike the older brother
yeah Derek she's got a smile that it
seems to me reminds me and child why man
is so flat twelve hundred dollars a week
for vocal lessons for nothing alright
I'll pick it back up bow back about that
I am Derrick is me and Jackie watch
stepbrothers over the weekend before we
fell asleep in Philadelphia we didn't
finish it and I've been meaning to
finish it because it's such a funny
[ __ ] movie it's so many great
one-liners came from it that like you
notice from Step Brothers but it's like
you don't even realize that like this
wedding is horseshit and then also you
big that curly-haired [ __ ] it's such a
good movie
it says to me and I hadn't seen it from
the beginning and so long and it's just
so good it's so good I recommend it
anyways oh wow and I can see her
I'm a little boy in the back 1,000% um
okay
ariana grande Liz Gillies Matt Bennett
like victorious ringing and thank you
next so much for days you know it's so
funny though about Matt Bennett it's
like he's really remained so relevant in
the Victoria sphere when he was like a
relatively like unknown character like
nobody really cared about him he wasn't
important like if you would have asked
me would have stuck together like you
would have thought the stars I'm a Jogia
you know I used to be obsessive about
Joey do you wanna know what it is it's
the power of friendship really it is
it's like you you're like your
friendship with someone like ariana
grande they can just take you to all new
heights you know so true like I just
wish I had like had been a child actor
who was on Victorious and became friends
in Ariana Grande but do you know did she
went in on Victoria definitely not with
Dan Schneider no definitely not
definitely definitely not - definitely
not what's that from just never others
no definitely definitely not what a
minute
anyways also Madison Brown I think was
there and you know she's obsessed with
ariana grande and she wrote living
legends on her Instagram uh the the Zac
saying show thing is so funny oh I
haven't seen it
the interview because my brows from
dynasty she's on the show with Liz
Gillies those Achilles was there she
also like was dating Liam Hemsworth very
briefly they might still be that she's
like working in Atlanta so we'll see um
but she was talking about on the show
that they did together how she loves
ariana and when this was in the video
like she died yeah that's so cool I'm
happy for her that she was able to the
concert like looks like we have to move
to Atlanta see you guys later see you
guys later anyways I just thought that
was psych oh speaking of people from
Atlanta curious to get your take Kim
Zolciak Biermann says daughter Ariana
can get her lips done now that she's 18
but she got them done already stop lying
Kim Zolciak Biermann who's been getting
lip fillers with pride for years and
passed down a predilection for plumpness
- were 22 year old daughter Brielle now
Kim's 18 year old daughter Ariana may be
ready for some enhancements of her own
are you sure that she's had them Josh
yes he does she have him on the show
well so that's a good question her
Instagram is so nuts I feel like for for
a while she was like really different
than Kim it and Brielle like she didn't
care about makeup and hair and she was
like kind of a tomboy like was really
into school and her studies and her
friends and then like literally they
went on break
and all of a sudden she comes back and
she looks just like Brielle she face
students her photos so much um but she
went through it on the show last season
like just she went prom dress shopping
and like nothing no dresses fit her and
she was like so upset because she got a
free dress from Sherri Hill and the
Sherri Hills one didn't fit it was like
so relatable and I wish she didn't face
in her photos so much because I actually
really related to her even though she's
like 12 and she looks so different there
is no time a time that she got at least
something done and now she's probably
gonna be more obvious about it but she
definitely has gotten worked on already
well Kim told Entertainment Tonight well
now she's 18 so I was like do it I think
she's been dying to be 18 so that she
could do something like that or do her
lips or whatever it's so pretty
the last few years in the show like she
didn't care about any of the stuff she
was like a bad kid it was just like
sneaking out with her friends and she
was a really a tomboy and I always had
boys over playing basketball like she
it's just like sad like she would never
really cared about this stuff yeah well
I know she's a cool glam everywhere she
goes
it is like sad because you know it's
cosmetic surgery and the kids are so
young and everyone's like worried about
what they look like an Instagram but
then on the other hand like look what it
did for Kylie Jenner like she is a
billionaire because she got her lips
done thousand percent but that's like
you know many people get their lips done
in are poor like yeah well I know but
I'm just saying like it's not always
just like a negative thing like
sometimes it can inspire you to build a
brown know for sure but I think Kylie's
was so successful because it came from
this genuine insecurity of hers where
does like I don't think Arianna ever
cared but yeah I guess it's like when
something really bothers you and it's
like it's you know clouding how you feel
about yourself like and you have the
means and we have the technology for you
to fix that like I think that's a great
thing and then you mention and that's
always like a great it's a healthy
mindset and when I was watching botched
like you should get a boob job for
yourself not for a men or because you
care what like how it perceives you're
supposed to look yeah but um yeah when
people are just doing it because and
also now what's so crazy is like the
it's like everything is so relative that
like now everyone has big lips right and
I'm someone who is now actually big lips
and like my lips are sometimes like
small compared to everyone no totally
[ __ ] your son I don't like when you guys
were getting your lips and I was like
when that we all have the same size like
what we don't have the same size there's
a huge supersize me
yeah supersize me those are crazy
documentary yeah so dumb um but back to
Ariana Biermann she definitely had
worked on already it is very sad
because I don't think that this is
something that she actually ever really
cared about or wanted and now like once
you do it then like you obviously get
into it but I just think like that's
never a reason to get something done
like a genuine insecurity that bothers
you for a really long time like that is
when you take action yeah you know
actually as someone who had their lips
done yeah how do you think that it
affected your life but you're also
twenty-four years old
yeah it's very different I'm actually 25
um yeah you got them when you were 24
and I'm just trying to keep you young
sis so I would never correct you I feel
very split about my lips and it just
depends on my mood because sometimes I
feel like I wish I never got them done
and I was like I didn't really need it
and then I'll see a picture of myself
like oh my god I did need it like with
you know a very old picture and say my
time how I used to look back and be like
oh I was so fat now I look back I'm like
oh my god I was so fat many tiny lips
like so I go back and forth within it I
don't feel as strongly about my lips as
I do about my chin like my chin was the
best thing that ever happened to me and
my weight fluctuates a lot but my face
doesn't change that much which I I don't
really care about I gained weight like
I'm not one of those people who like is
affected by it like I'm fat I'm skinny
I'm so happy both times but when I see
my face getting big like it does affect
my self-esteem so getting this chin
procedure like helps that yeah and I
have absolutely no regrets
I don't care like I would how much time
it took how much money it cost how much
pain I was in like I would do it all
again and I would do it double you know
like it was about and that's how you
should feel when you get something done
and that's because you did something
that like bothered you for a long tour a
long time not just like oh I like it's
not like putting a filter on yourself
you know right it's not like it's a big
deal no I think these kids I hope
they're thinking these things through
yeah but everyone should do what they
want but but then at the same time I
just hate when people come from for
other people for having plastic surgery
or like getting fillers like that's
their [ __ ] business like [ __ ] all
right and like the biermann's they'll
see a family like obviously you know
they they love to hit that needle but
they like are so happy no they are so
happy you know they look like they are
feeling themselves at all times and like
that's like all your casing is just like
- all we want in this world is just
happy that I'm happy and if that's what
makes me happy like go for it and that's
what that's what helps you sleep at
night on your Helix mattress then that's
really all that matters
I mean sleeping at night anyway let's
smash this is already easy because you
have a helix mattress but when you can
feel good about yourself - it's like
dang you miss your alarm I just want to
say I'm ahead of the curve I had to heal
this mattress like starting three years
ago in my old apartment greatest thing
that ever happened to me because they
believe quiz which is great and they
help you and they ask you questions
about you
and your partner because as much as yes
I'm ordering the bed in doing all the
labor there are two people sleeping this
bad Ben prefers a much firmer vibe when
I'm definitely more of like a softer
cloud like chika helix sleep hub has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep reference to the perfect mattress
for you whether you're a side sleeper or
a hot sleeper are you like a plush or a
firm bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising on
average mattresses helix sleep was even
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick in 2019 by GQ and Wired
magazine go to helix sleep calm / toast
take their 2 minutes sleep quiz and
they'll match you a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out 400 nights
risk-free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will helix
is offering $200 off all mattresses for
our listeners at helix sleep comm /
toast again helix sleep is offering up
to $200 of off all mattresses for our
listeners at helix sleep dot-com / toast
that's helix h e li x sleep dot-com /
toast for up to $200 off helix sleep dot
slash toast sign on and fall asleep love
it okay yes yes I am
what happened obermann's weaning party
yeah and something that has been
happening for past few episodes where
it's like a game of telephone I don't
understand why they can't have a
mandatory thing where they all have to
talk to each other because Tamara brain
planning everything on Kelly Kelly
blaming everything on Tamara Shannon
like I just need everyone there hope
they would hash it out at the weaning
party and then Kelly Ben show up and
Kelly is kind of the center of us all so
that was really frustrating that makes
next weekend like look so good but
that's what happened last week yeah that
weenie party was out of control Bronwyn
is insane
grandma's insane and I just want to say
something because my verdict is in the
like the trial is over on the
inauguration of Rob Lowe and how do you
feel and I really like her yeah I think
and Kristen Chen with moves on Montreux
dive inside last night and she said
exactly what I was thinking I the other
way I loved Chris and Julie and
everything every time she was asked me
in my house I had the exact same pianist
and she's so well-spoken in articulate
and like she was making really good
point
oh my god in her saying
Joe Giudice should've left Isis was the
funniest thing ever but um I like
Bronwyn one because like she's standing
her ground and she's not spineless she's
not you know she's taking Kelly's head
when it's really not popular to take
Kelly start because a tres amigas we're
like the cool girls are not liking Kelly
yes so she I take back the spineless
comments that I've made and because as a
person her character and like her way of
life is different from anything we have
ever seen and I think it just brings
like a freshness to the show and she's
not embarrassed by it like she's so
quirky yeah she has her stuff in like
she raised 7 kids like let the woman do
what she wants I agree and I totally
understood the idea of a weaning party
I'm like a [ __ ] Gina making fun of
her like no I totally get it
I don't think yeah his blog I get it
yeah I completely get it and I just I
like the addition that she brings to the
show and I like the fact that she stands
up for her friends and she stands up for
herself
I totally that's where I am and I don't
really I don't I don't feel for like
strongly enough about either side in
this scenario to take a side like I do
think Kelly's crazy but I do think
Tamra's manipulative so I don't really
stand firmly on either side I just like
who I like and I like Kelly and I like
Bronwyn and I like Emily and like I'm
almost leaning more towards taking their
side even though like they're insane
like but I just I was watching us watch
rappin's live and I really like Emily
like I just do me too and I am in this
situation I am on their side because I
do think I think Shannon is is less
guilty to blame kind of like be just
like kind of a victim of everybody
really
I do think Tamra is being like a little
mean and a little messy and now she's
lying and by the way like she did say
train and when they were at coffee and
Tamara was like okay yes so like I
literally just said train like does that
mean I brought it up and Shannon was
like well some people could see it that
way like yeah yeah and and that is what
happened cause Vicki can make her veiled
threats all she wants but like she's not
putting she wasn't putting something
okay there okay so I think that really
it is on Tamra she's so confused as to
why only everyone's mad at her and so
crazy how like someone filmed them at
lunch coffee and it ended up becoming a
part of the storyline that got out
meeting it looked like Tamara was
already brought up the stairs yes
that was really crazy yeah sure and you
know what I really did throw a wrench in
like the storyline because then now
we're getting off track because also
because Tamara didn't say that instance
Tamara wasn't good and
it's gonna become about that yeah so
silly yeah so annoying
um and I do like I love Tamara she's
like one of the greatest housewives
she just needs to own up right now she's
just like lying and just everyone needs
to get cut together needs to be called
out I think the reunion will be great
because everyone will have seen the
footage yep um because I just like it's
just getting a little messy yeah I
thought that usually I find this stuff
very boring but I thought Shannon's
divorce hearings weren't very
interesting very interesting
um I'm absolutely shook that she could
end up with nothing because California
is notorious for just like community
property like everyone gets half of
everything and I just thought it was
that kind of like a great moment for
women like then just being like just
because he went out to work every day
and she literally raised their kids like
that's equal yeah and Buddha's are
paying probably saying like I raised my
husband seven kids and if he left me I'm
taking it all everything like not even
I'm getting my half yeah everything no
it's so true I mean Brahmin raised seven
[ __ ] kids she better take it
all but like I just thought it was like
a really great way to have that kind of
conversation like housewives is always
having like weird weirdly important
cultural conversation a completely a
great Shahs of Sunset and they think
that um where'd our squatters knock you
guys
are you hungry Oh No thirsty thirsty
okay so we have some water um also
Shannon I think like so many women have
been like on this journey with her
relate to her and like him fit in her
position and her and she's been so open
about every painful thing and it's like
oh my god it's like thank you to this
woman for this like just showing like
the dark side right oh but make no one
ever really talks about money like right
and I think it's like it's AIT's brave
but it's also just important like you
know you need to have these
conversations right like you need to
know if you're going to divorce like
Shannon beador is a great point of
reference like was Chani got this I want
that yeah um but we wasn't gonna say oh
what was what was really interesting was
I'm talking about her salary and the
housewives is now kind of throwing a
wrench in her divorce proceedings
because like if she didn't technically
have a job would you assume that she
doesn't but the show is her job she
would probably be getting way more money
and they're using that against her now
but she keeps saying that she's making
less money this year than she was last
year which I'm fine interesting maybe
because of the QVC thing
maybe this year she invested more in
this new business she's building a
website and like next year it'll come to
fruition whereas the year before she
went on QVC and she had made quick money
yeah maybe but her salary should be
going up yeah right yeah the list on the
show yeah yeah that was interesting
yeah also it's like this judge like
absolutely needs to arch housewives and
then like then it's almost like unfair
when a housewife or like a Teresa is
going through because they should get
more lenient because you're getting it
like an inside look into what they're
actually feeling and if the judge or the
jury like does watch Housewives of New
Jersey or does know Shannon beador like
it almost makes it unfair well I think
in its they're both different I think
with Teresa it makes it up there for her
because she doesn't look great on the
show and she's spending above her meat
right and they're seeing like this
stolen money being spent on a house that
they can't afford right but we know
francha but with Shannon if a judge or a
jury watched it they would 100% side
with her like David was an animal and
then there was those allegations that he
hit her like it's just she's what
happened she's been nothing but a
precious angel she squashed it because
she's a good mom yes she's a good mom
also um the Key West of it all that was
interest on I feel like it really
roundabout way it's just like you could
say I feel like it was like a little
dramatic seeing as how she thinks it
might be where they start there there I
understand I actually I understand I
just also wouldn't want to go to Cuba
but that's a whole other places that you
could go why don't you go to post a my
list I feel like for people who like
specially in California like they don't
really know Key West it's such a
specific place that it's like all it is
to her is David's affair right it's not
like everyone in New York City like
there's a million things like right
sounds like there's one who Italian team
I didn't realize that brought it almost
from Miami yeah I guess they lived there
for a while and she was like once the
girls see me in Miami they'll understand
me more no I don't agree you know I just
think we just need to keep seeing you
and Joe be ashamed and I'm understanding
when she was addressing everyone she was
like thinking even though like I know
I'm really you know really annoyed by me
like I want you to come on the ship that
was funny she was she's so funny and
yeah elsewhere and I guess that Bravo
con she was saying that she was drunk
the whole season um and that's what
Tamra is saying about her that she I
guess she really has been like drunk a
full season but not in like an alcoholic
way but just maybe in like a fun excited
but every yeah everything is centered
around drinking yeah so she drank it
weird um I find it so interesting that
Vicki really doesn't like like the
strippers like she left and they were
saying how like she never has been into
that I feel like she would very much
like to whoop it up and like she would
be into that yeah I mean everyone has
their own things but then her saying
like I don't need a sex swing like I
have to steal aaj like stop please stop
please please now stop stop
you know it was really not in the
episode which is maybe why I enjoyed it
was Jeana I find Jeana so [ __ ]
annoying and like I can really get
behind all the women like I don't love
all of them all the time but like I
understand I understand them and and I
do like I believe in them I just I
cannot get behind Jeana that's so funny
because there's something about me where
I just understand Jeana
oh my god I totally disagree I find her
so [ __ ] annoying and fake and losery
and just like really wanting to be a
part of the cool crew even if it's like
she kind of gives me like Sheena hi it's
like Marina just like ditched Ariana who
was like a really good friend her but
just because she wanted to be with the
cool cool but she hasn't did she has a
ditch I'm just in her and Emily are good
right I just find her like going in that
direction like and valuing like things
and friendships like for different bad
reasons yeah I understand how you could
see it that way but I see it where it's
like she values these Witold er wiser
popular women because they've been
through what she's gone through and all
she wants is an answer for what to do
she doesn't know what to do okay well
it's about to do figure it out like
Shannon door everyone's stiffer chatham
doors not gonna help you
you know but she but she is also just
like seeing precedent what happened to
Shannon like it's just it's helpful and
that's what they were saying to each
others like you have you have us all
you've got is your us your girlfriend's
when Bronwyn was like any one of us
would take a bullet for you and Emily's
like we would bury a body for you oh
yeah we would we do I that I thought
that was funny Ben actually laughter
that like for the first time ever he
like pretends he doesn't like it he's
like Bronwyn she's so crazy yeah I think
they're only a really good place yeah it
was fine episode it was good episode but
I need justice for Kelly God me too
because she's a lot of things but like
in this instance like she's just been
conversation is Chatham and she like
stormed out and left was like weirdly
amicable I feel like they might have
edited it to make it look like she
stormed out storming out of the lunch
outside with Shannon oh it was so like
comedy I just feel like she did in the
storm out like maybe like she got up
first and then they made it look like a
storm yeah also the Jim Bellino drops oh
that's so crazy
ever been more person
bring Mac Alexis Bellino I couldn't
agree more it kind of made it seem like
Emily was taking Jim Bellino side uh no
actually emily is just friends with a
lot less Alexis and Jim are divorced you
know I know but
and then Butler when she started
speaking you know she's gonna defend
Tamara but she was saying to you like
you can't just say stuff about people
right I mean he obviously has a case
he's suing then yeah and if it's causing
that much money like it's not being
dismissed like it's legit yeah I mean I
wonder what they said about him on the
podcast and if the podcast is getting
like tons of reviews because of it right
like someone come on here actually for a
while I heard the OC housewives couldn't
do podcasts cuz they're out of control
cuz they were just like saying too much
stuff yeah which is why we we've only
ever had time right yeah I think that's
me putting pieces together interesting
yeah um cool yeah
also I want to talk about Vicki at Bravo
con she was saying like she's coming
back for her orange next season
so who do you think would lose an orange
what does someone have to lose no but
like it would be so weird if they kept
the cast the same they just Simona Vicki
I'm around her back and like I think I
wouldn't demote anyone right now
yeah which is a good sign yeah that is a
good time also Kelly got engaged I know
I'm I'm her ring is stunning she's
saying that she wants to move to New
York because it's a he lives in New York
and Ramona set her up and now she wants
much new houses in New York I would kind
of be here for it I would be here and
they to really use and with the loss of
Bethenny like they can use an injection
of Kelly Dodd I'm really had like high
hopes for Liam McCarthy
I don't know McSweeney next week so I
watch to watch their happens live um
Tinsley was wise nobody's saying how
Tinsley was blackout like she literally
was slurring her words she was crazy for
sure but by the way I would be too okay
so did she get new teeth or have we
never seen her smile so she looks
different I don't know what it is
there's something different I think she
was smiling so like we saw her whole
gums like maybe she's just never been
this happy yeah that's what I was
curious about um I have some thoughts on
the production of the watch what happens
live I think that while it was as good
as it could have been it was still a
little bit messy like when they were
like sitting people down and taking out
new people but people are still standing
up and the crowd was like really [ __ ]
annoying yeah I think that they need to
figure something else out yeah we make
some changes okay for next year but I
think they did a good job what were your
other takeaways um so we were talking
about this yesterday um
cloudy called me two times to tell me
this cuz they did figure out Mercedes
sha beam and Kyle Richards both were
wearing that red trophy trust that I
have it was the same one but different
colors also twisted Judah
it comes in a midi-length almost looks
like a robe like a caftan she was
wearing it in like a black pattern so
three people were technically wearing
the same dress but in different
variations like I just thought that was
worth noting great I also thought the
way that they had people sit was
interesting and like Caroline Manzo and
Lisa Vanderpump didn't have to say and I
think that if Caroline Manzo wants to be
the gets the prestige of Bravo con she
should have to sit while Teresa is
talking yeah I mean same as Lisa
Vanderpump yeah Davers they respect me
hotter what did you think about my
thought on Ramona
oh she was hilarious by the way when
they were doing and the the beef thing
and then they kept Ramona's face and
just like I did watch oh she's something
else that was so funny she was hilarious
not that she handled it well I thought
the only thing that she could've handled
better was Giselle she was rude like
yeah and I'd like to self-respond she
was like you did hurt my feelings like I
didn't go home and cry for a bit but
that was also her first one I think she
was when Dora said you didn't hurt my
feelings she was breaking down her walls
the apologies were happening wait when
the first beef was [ __ ] Captain Lee
and Jax I was dying that was so funny
and like so random jets his Twitter
because everyone um also we spoke about
this on our podcast yesterday but I have
gotten multiple confirmations about the
whole drama with the sweatshirts we
spoke that on Monday on Monday's episode
we were unsure if Jax was coming after
this Etsy girl like for copying her or
if Jackson's copying that sea girl and
pretty much everyone has basically
proven that Jax and Kristen were second
like it was the girl on Etsy who had the
idea first and she's been selling them
for a while and they just kind of copied
it yeah that's like an interesting
territory because like they're making
she's making fan merge and I think I
don't know what you can't unless she has
a trademark and then they're copying her
but there she's also using his name and
I think the best way to go about it is
like Nick James make and make the shirts
if they want but like they're trying to
shut this girl down and like make her
seem like she's like a liar and that she
has shitty like everyone could just make
the shirt right you know when you come
back from whoever you want you know yeah
there's something unethical about them
just selling it though because there is
the like ASA but they're but she's using
their name and likeness I get it but
just seems like she's like it's a weenie
it's a weird area but intellectual
property it's not nice that they're
making her seem like some sort of thief
yeah when she's not and like she
obviously makes like premium Bravo merch
and initialize a hill I didn't see
but like just steal it in silence and
like don't hugger it agreed you know um
I believe that's all we have for you for
today thank you so much you guys for
hanging out with us at the morning toast
a millennial Morning Show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on you Chuck you see the
new trailer for cats yes it is DC's
names big sister Aegis Elba what about I
didn't see any means just breasts
breasts the female cats have like
breasts did you yeah titties yeah like
they happen they put a pencil underneath
oh definitely not they're so perky okay
Sophie oh definitely can't stand up
today though oh no Theo should be in cat
says like the dog who shows them up um
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning to assemble in a morning
show when we go live Monday to Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found there's a brand
new episode of our new TNN show mood
with or elizabeth that dropped this
morning i think you guys will really
like it she did the podcast collab also
um Kate night with Raven and Adam
they're having episode on Monday but
they were on Caitlin I know Katie Warhol
broke up night and did you see the
videos the toasters we're posting a she
was discussing the Raven drama yeah the
Rachel drama okay chill drama and it was
really sad Oh like she was just saying
like she's sad about it but I mean a
loss of a friendship actually said about
it I'm sad about it and make sure to get
your new Jackie O flow presets fall and
winter Jackie O flow W of all winter
2019 you guys it's everything you need
for that for those steamy vibes through
fall tickets available to the girl with
no job dirty jeans torrid girls on top
calm we have tickets left in Verona New
York Kansas City Missouri and Englewood
New Jersey Atlantic City New Jersey and
Rama Ontario that is where I'll be next
week hey we love you guys this episode
is ending and you're a miss devastated
and heartbroken about it fret no more
because there's so much premium content
for you at patreon.com slash and morning
toast if you joined right now you get
like over 20 episodes you could listen
until the until the holidays until the
end of time tomorrow is our last episode
of the week until we had on vacation we
hope you guys have a great Thanksgiving
but we'll see you tomorrow so tomorrow
you